do you have anybody in your family that
overextended themselves by trying to
help everybody in their family that
eventually led to a divorce and a
bankruptcy can you think about that
person I want you to think about this
year let's just say you're making sixty
three thousand dollars per year which is
roughly fifty two hundred dollars per
month what percentage of that income
would you be comfortable giving to aging
parents to help them out on a monthly
basis maybe you said ten percent what's
ten percent roughly 500 a month fine now
you may say why are we using sixty three
thousand dollars here's why because if
you add eight additional zeros to it you
would come out with America's income
which is roughly 6.3 trillion dollars
however do you know what percentage of
that income America uses for entitlement
programs ready 52 that means if you made
sixty three thousand dollars per year
you would give 33 000 away for
entitlement programs that's what we're
doing in America right now by the way of
the 3.3 trillion dollars on entitlement
program 1.3 trillion of it is only
towards welfare that's 59 million
Americans that on a monthly basis
receive a welfare check 19 percent of
America so the question becomes is this
sustainable how long can America go
until we go bankrupt we're going to talk
about that today okay so if you give Ali
out of this video give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel let's get
right into it so why are we talking
about welfare because Biden just
proposed that he wants to take that 1.3
trillion dollars of which 756 goes to
Medicaid 208 goes to other income
security 147 goes to food and nutrition
like food stamps 124 goes to Housing
section 8 70 billion goes to
unemployment President Biden wants to
raise that to 2.6 trillion dollars and
it stays like that till
2033 costing you and I roughly 12.7
trillion dollars over the next 10 years
okay so now let's break that down the
2.6 trillion dollars to see where that
money is going to be spending let's look
all the way at the top child tax credit
expansion for three years 470 billion
dollars by the way we're going to go a
little bit bit deeper into this program
to see what that program is really all
about government Child Care 424
government Paid Family Leave 325
government preschool 200 billion four
states to expand Medicaid 200 billion
expand Indian Health Service 185
Medicaid home and community-based Care
150 expand eitc 137 billion expand
Obamacare subsidies 130 billion then we
have double Pell Grant 96 billion free
Community College 90 billion expand
housing subsidies 60 billion Public
Health 43 billion Behavioral Health
equity-based tuition subsidies expand
School Meal subsidies extend trait
adjustment assistance and Medicaid
nutrition coverage total 2.6 trillion
dollars it's interesting when I'm
looking at these numbers because Jake
euger and I got into a debate
specifically over this topic you'll see
what it is but let me first explain to
you what this child tax credit is you
know what's the crazy thing about all
this money we're printing every time we
print trillions let's do 2.6 trillion
dollars guess who that money goes to it
goes to low and middle income but low
and middle income families don't know
how to keep their money they spend their
money and that money eventually flows to
who to the wealthy and what increases
value these non-duplicatable assets one
of the classes being alternative assets
such as art this is why today's sponsor
is Masterwork so what does Masterworks
look you know how many times we watch
and say oh wow look at Jamie diamonds
got a 900 million art collection but I
can't afford to buy art like that but me
King can afford to buy a piece of art
maybe a share of It kind of like you buy
stock and apple but you can buy the
whole three trillion dollar company
that's when Masterworks start they buy a
million dollar painting for example and
you're able to own a piece of it while a
single return is not a guarantee of
future returns their 15th exit of
painting a Cecily Brown piece just sold
a few days ago for a return of 77.3
percent annualized net return again
that's not a guarantee but this is one
thing you need to know the last 27 years
Blue Chip whole contemporary art has
outpaced the S P 500 by an impressive
136 percent that's pretty impressive and
by the way collectively I think all art
stuff sold Masterworks is around 45
million dollars so if you want to
participate with Masterworks they got
790 000 users now roughly 800 million
dollars of assets under management so if
you again if you can't own own a Warhol
or Banksy or Picasso yourself but you
want to own a share of it you can go to
masterworks.com forward slash
valuetainment or click on the link below
to get access today the American Rescue
plan increased the amount of child tax
credit from 2000 to 3 600 for qualifying
children under eight six and three
thousand dollars for other qualifying
children under the age of 18. so just
think about it the more kids you have
and if you're not in a marriage you get
more money given to you by the
government guess what that incentivizes
we're going to talk about that here in a
minute wait till you see the data on
that second one child care Biden 2024
proposal includes 22 billion dollars for
existing early care and education
programs up from ten and a half percent
from 2023 levels including 9 billion for
federal block rents Paid Family Leave
the proposed program would provide
workers up to 12 paid weeks off to bond
with a new child care for a family
member or heal from their own serious
illness so now you may be watching the
same Pat I get it where are you going
with this I you know we have to help
these people they need help what should
we do just leave them alone well let me
give you an idea how we got you because
if you don't pay attention to this stuff
you're paying for it your taxes are
going to increase during the Great
Depression FDR wanted to come out with a
temporary solution to help those who
couldn't take care of themselves
eventually by 1935 at the State of Union
Address FDR declared the time has come
for Action by the national government to
provide security against the major
hazards and uncertainties of life he
went on to propose the creation of
federal unemployment the old age
insurance program he also called for
Guarantee benefits for poor single
mothers and their children along with
other dependent persons and a few months
later the Social Security Act
established a national welfare system
keep in mind prior to this time we don't
have entitlement programs okay we're
getting by with no entitlement programs
all of a sudden he announces this it's
supposed to be temporary and guess what
happens becomes permanent but the key
word here is the following guaranteed
benefits for poor single mothers and
their children along with other
dependent persons let's see they say bad
policies as consequences did this
influence how many new single mothers we
had in America did it influence how our
kids did let's look at the data so this
chart right here is from the US
Government Census Bureau okay and it's
showing you the growth of unwed
childbearing in U.S from 29. notice if
you look at 1935 flat less than four
percent of the babies born are born to a
single mother that means 96 of all
babies born in 1940 were born to a
family where there's a mother and a
father 96 then that goes from there to
now 40 percent of babies being born are
born to a single mother not married no
father figure you know what this tells
you we can look at one other deity if
you go to 1964 which was the war on
poverty this is the program that Lyndon
Johnson came up with he launched a
Medicare Medicaid and expanded housing
subsidies Urban Development programs
employment and training programs food
stamps Social Security welfare benefits
these programs more than tripled Real
Federal expenditure on health education
and Welfare which grew to over 15 70 of
the federal budget by 1970. today it's
at 52 percent take a look at what
happens after 64 as well Spike to 40
percent so somebody may say well you
know how dare you make these comparisons
why would you do this it's called data
and the great thing about data is the
more years you have to see if
something's working or not the proof
isn't a pudding this doesn't lie this is
numbers these were bad policies that
incentivized women to have kids out of
wedlock it's not me telling you this
it's the data telling you this so you
may say Pat I need more data no problem
I'll give you more data here's another
one to look at again from the U.S Census
Bureau if you look at this this is total
families with children from 1959 till
today if you look at this look at the
top married couple families with
children it's 25 000 you gotta add three
zeros to it because it's in thousands
which means 25 million we've been pretty
much the same during that 60-year period
whatever the timeline is but if you look
at the bottom in the red single parent
families which children we have three x
in 60 years more people are saying all
good I'm gonna have more kids with no
husband or wife being in the household
together these kids are being raised by
a single parent now you may say Pat I
mean it's just one program it's not like
we have so many different programs let
me read you all the programs and you
tell me if you heard of these before
first one earn income tax credit the ITC
temporary assistant for needy families
ta and F the women infants and children
food program WIC supplemental Social
Security food stamps and Child Nutrition
programs public housing and Section 8
Housing and Medicaid by the way while
married couples will children can also
receive aid from these programs most
assistance to families with children
goes to single parent households 45.4
percent of families headed by single
mothers receive Food Stamps 51.4 percent
of single mothers have never been
married welfare programs financially
enable single Parenthood who does it
hurt the kids and if the kids are raised
without discipline who doesn't hurt your
neighborhood so this next part I'm going
to read it to you what I want to
challenge you to do is actually follow
it with me and listen to it while we're
going through this you'll see why let's
read this together a major problem is
that the means tested welfare system
actively penalizes low-income parents
ready who do marry who do marry you're
incentivized if you don't marry you're
penalized if you do get married all
means tested welfare programs are
designed so that a family's benefits are
reduced as earnings rise the more money
you make and you're independent your
benefits go lower you're like why would
I work harder to make more money my
benefits are getting lower I'm not going
to work so you're going to send me money
I am that's what that means in practice
this means if a low-income single mother
marries an employed father her welfare
benefits will generally be substantially
reduced the mother can maximize Welfare
by remaining unmarried and keeping the
father's income off the books tell me
that makes any sense for you if this is
the incentive program that we have what
do you think people are going to do
exactly what it takes to maximize the
benefits without having to work for
example a single mother with two
children who earns fifteen thousand
dollars per year would generally receive
around fifty two hundred dollars per
year of food stamps benefits however if
she marries a father with the same
earnings level her food stamps would be
cut to zero a single mother receiving
benefits from section 8 or public
housing would receive a subsidy worth on
average around eleven thousand dollars
per year if she was not employed but if
she marries a man earning twenty
thousand dollars per year those benefits
would be cut nearly in half both food
stamps and Housing Programs provide very
real Financial incentives for couples to
remain separated and unmarried so some
people only say Pat stop it you know we
have to take care of these folks it's
not like these people are not
self-sufficient why are you
discriminating amongst these people let
me give you more data I'm gonna give you
two of them marriage promotes
self-sufficiency these are percentages
of families with children that lack
self-sufficiency you see the 37.1
percent this is single parent female
headed families don't 37.1 percent of
them lack self-sufficiency they need you
and I the government taxpayers to take
care of them but look at the other side
married parent families only 6.8 percent
need help that means 93.2 percent are
self-sufficient and this next one is my
favorite chart you know why because so
many times you'll do something and at
the beginning it looks good you see it's
working look how awesome it is look what
we're doing to reduce poverty but you
know what this data shows it shows it
took us 55 years to realize how terrible
of an idea this was take a look at this
chart so 1947 if you look at all the way
to the left top percentage of
individuals who were poor by the
official poverty standard keeps going
lower and lower and lower what a noble
program by FDR and boom 64. Lyndon
Johnson lower lower lower and they go to
1990. look at the red total means tested
welfare spending in billions of constant
dollars goes Higher and Higher and
Higher and blue stays and this chart
only goes to 2012. it's an additional 11
years since then we're at 52 percent of
the 6.3 trillion and by the way this
ends in 2013. there's an additional 10
years to it what do you think it
happened you think it went lower it went
higher and higher and higher today it's
52 entitlement programs 59 million
Americans receive welfare program today
how long can we go with this to sustain
it we can't sustain it today let alone
10 more years 20 more years and while
politicians you know what they're saying
oh you are so selfish if you decide to
get rid of these entitlement programs
there is no way you should re-elect this
individual why he's giving you a good
ideas or she's giving you good ideas but
you're playing off of fear because
you've given people so many free
entitlement programs that they're
addicted to it you know who does things
like that you ever heard of drug dealers
what they do they give you a little bit
of crack or cocaine or whatever and then
eventually a little bit for free then
hey pay up and pay up now like they
can't get off of it what happens you
ruined that person's life these people
the 59 million what percentage of their
dreams they think is going to become a
reality what do you think all of that
was taken away from them done done
just because you give a little bit of
drugs let's replace it with some
entitlement programs same consequences
you're hurting these people long term
you're loving them over short term but
you're destroying their lives long term
so a few things I've been watching the
same pad you know what do you want us to
do do we just cut this whole thing all
of us and of course we can't do that
suddenly but what if we take that 3.3
trillion hours that we have and every
year we cut a 10 meaning 3.3 goes to
three goes to 2.7 maybe 2.5 maybe 2.3
maybe 2.1 eventually within the next 15
20 years we're down to a very small
amount of money that we're given to this
oh Pat there's no way that would I
understand it's not going to because
these congressmen with unlimited terms
they can run they're never going to pass
something like this because you need
term limits and they're not going to let
that happen I'm just telling you that's
the solution because long term if you
don't agree to this you know who's
getting screwed the kids and our
grandkids and all we're saying is guys
you can handle it you go out and handle
all these problems I'll give you another
one here for you as well if we're
rewarding behavior for people to have
more kids and we're going to give them
entitlement programs what do you think
people are going to do what if we do the
other way around what if we reward
people who are married having kids with
their job what if we do that oh my God
you think people will change of course
I've changed I've ran a sales
organization for 23 years I've run my
own insurance company for the last 14
years do you know how many times I
change the Compensation Program 50 60 70
times you know what happens when I had a
comp where people were writing bogus
Insurance business where they were just
kind of writing business because they
were competing and I changed it
overnight all the bogus business
disappeared like literally overnight the
bad business disappeared because the
incentive program I came up with wasn't
a good one so we had to change it what
happened suddenly everyone's income went
up and the people that you know were
doing their thing that were improving
they were making an effort to get better
because the incentive program changed we
also have to change the incentive
programs that we have but last but not
least let me give you the most important
one I got four kids my dad when I was I
don't know how old I was eight years old
nine years old told me a story about
being a man he says Pat let me tell you
the story here I told the story in
Austin a couple weeks ago he said this
to me says Pat one day father wakes up
his son it was summer so the kid wasn't
going to school he said son today you're
going to become a man he says women mean
I'm going to become a man you need to go
out there and make five dollars today
the son says Dad I'm I'm 12 years old
I'm 11 years old what do you mean I need
to go make five dollars you need to go
make five dollars a day to be a mentor
so Dad come on dad I'm a kid no really
boom Papa leaves dad leaves son is like
five dollars my God Mom I shouldn't work
it's not safe out there Mom says don't
worry about it baby here's five dollars
when Daddy comes home just give it to
him that you made five dollars it's
between you and I no problem that comes
on did you make your five dumps of
course dad I made the five dollars
here's the five dollars daddy awesome
dad grabs of five dollars throws it in
the fireplace the fire starts burning
the five dollars mommy chases after the
five dollars daddy realized Mommy gave
the kid five dollars he says son you
didn't make the five dollars kid goes to
sleep feels like crap wakes up in the
morning Dad says Hey today you got to
make five dollars that goes to work son
goes to Mom hey Mom can I give I'm not
giving you nothing he's not gonna burn
another five dollars a mind you gotta go
figure this thing out song goes out
starts begging everybody in the
community starting with his uncle and
his uncle finally after baking a few
different relatives he raises five
dollars through begging entitlement
programs through begging he gets five
bucks comes home mom guess what I got
five dollars I talked to Uncle this
Uncle that Auntie this awesome good job
babe dad comes home son did you make
five dollars yeah Daddy look at this
five one dollar bills dad grabs the
phone throws in the fire why would you
do that you didn't make five dollars how
do you know trust me I know tomorrow you
best make five dollars dad wakes up goes
to son hey five dollars today goes to
work Mom no begging no and she goes
across the street to say I mean can I
work for you I need to make five dollars
today or else my dad's gonna shoot me
out he said I can't give you five
dollars but I give you a penny for each
sandbag you move from here to over there
only a penny only a penny this kid 11 12
years old only moves 150 sandbags it's a
buck 50 and change that comes home son
is sweaty dirty hands so son did you
make five dollars he says no I made a
dollar fifty puts the money in Dad's
hands dad grabs the money throws it in
the fireplace the Sun runs into the
fireplace starts picking up this money
that hugs him he says son today I know
for a fact you work for that dollar
fifty you know why because you were
willing to burn your hands because you
paid the price for this you're
officially a man I am so proud of you I
think we need to start believing in the
American people that you are better than
this you can figure out a way to make
money if you're not in a good situation
to have kids don't have kids I think too
many people are pressured to have kids
simply because of these bogus incentive
programs that we have if we start
believing in our people we change the
incentive programs we challenge our guys
to start dreaming again having valuing
themselves again eventually one day
we're going to wake up realizing we
don't need to waste all our money your
money my money 52 on people and steal
their dreams away from them instead
we've developed a whole new generation
of leaders and America's future looks
bright if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel and I got another video for
you if you've never watched the history
of Social Security click here to watch
it take care everybody bye-bye
foreign